now it's time to make a choice but the
stakes have been so grounded and
character focused thus far I mean this
is a lot of new information to put into
one hour join me or I will destroy the
universe I'm gonna pretend like that's a
hard choice to make for a couple of
seconds go ahead you believe killing is
bad I don't you're saying something
really interesting here well what do you
say I say
no I am Superhero now and one day you'll
see me appear for two minutes in an
Avengers movie
maybe it looks like our differences are
irreconcil of what now we fight for 30
minutes destroy a couple of buildings
then you make a speech trying to make
sense of everything okay I'm still gonna
let you live all right